all right gina we have to act soon that
cold medicine diaz chugged it was the
non-drowsy kind she's all over the place
hey hey hey hey guess what yeah i got a
new lead to ask my purpose is a drug
dealer on state
street
why doesn't someone answer that thought
get it i'll get it
hello i know there's no michael here you
have the wrong number goodbye
i'm michael that's a dumb name but it's
yours and you should be proud of it
because you are the greatest detective
i've ever known no doy do you have no
door where is my file yeah
she's so hopped up on that stuff her
brain's gonna blow i'm gonna interrogate
the perv you keep diaz occupied i don't
want to get near her germ face
permission to lock her in a distant room
no just distract her yes
that is what i will do
come here
i've got to tell you something it's a
secret okay
but i have a lot of stuff to do secretly
everything okay with diaz yeah she fell
asleep five minutes after i locked her
in and she hasn't moved in the past 10
hours
she talks in her sleep
i'm gonna rip your head off i'm gonna
rip your damn head off grandma oh tear
bear what if she sleeps forever
oh look rosa you look great girl i gotta
get out of here bye better not run
because i will catch you after i'm done
crushing that perp you are next i
already interrogated the perp for you
you what i got him to name his giggle
pig supplier it's all good now go home
and get better i could have done it
myself no you couldn't have you
literally have been in a coma since
yesterday now i know you like to act
like you don't need any help but we all
do
look i ask five dudes to spot me when
i'm doing my squats terry paid me 20 to
lock you up no i did not but i took that
cheddar and i made you this special
rosa's gonna make this called her [ __ ]
care package
now's the time where you say thank you
for all your help
thank you for all your help
wait is that a smile i see
possibly
my immune system is too weak to fight
off my smile muscles
why do you think you're gonna hire that
bi to mock us
she's scared
she's not scared with all due respect
sir
gina has no feelings she once said the
best comedy of all time was the girl
with the dragon tattoo well think about
how she's been acting
gina came by my house last night do i
buy an uzi i asked for a police officer
to escort me to work and it took a while
for dispatch to find me a young kevin
costner type
her home doesn't feel safe anymore
if someone broke into your apartment and
you weren't cops
wouldn't you be scared
yes
depends
how many guns do i still have hidden no
do i stole my knife
nunchucks
acts
it was a hypothetical question i know
but i want to play it out
do i solve my throwing stars
this has taken a strange turn
fine
i'd be scared
we're on it
kind of woman doesn't have an ax
what are you doing i'm just sealing
jason's collar in an airtight bag so it
retains his scent
i don't know how many whiffs i have left
wow
look i know that dog meant a lot to you
so i got you this
it's a dog
his name's arlo but you can call him
jason too or whatever seriously i can't
just replace jason with some other dog
why not all dogs are basically the same
watch this arlo go hump that toy
get away from that
that's jason's
look man
i've been patient but we have a case we
need to work on it's time for you to get
over it move on move on
move on
jason was part of my family rosa i loved
him his humping was the only thing that
got me through my divorce seeing him so
happy made me believe that i could be
happy one day too
you wouldn't understand this because you
have a motorcycle helmet for a heart but
i need to feel this sadness so the only
thing that i'm moving on from is you
so i like have a dog now
briefing room now
i really don't feel like having a yell
at me anymore
what is this it's a funeral for jason
i'm gonna say a few words
when jason died seven days ago i didn't
give a rat's ass this is your speech
cause i didn't understand why people
care so much about their dumb dogs until
i got a dumb dog myself
i've only had arlo for a day and a half
but if anything happened to him i would
kill everyone in this room and then
myself
very violent eulogy i like it charles
i'm sorry you don't have to get over it
take as long as you want scully it's
time
[Music]
oh you're back how did the breakup go i
tried to acknowledge his feelings
it wasn't easy there were a lot of them
just so confused
so sad
are you climbing out the window
no i climbed back in and we talked about
emotions for 20 minutes dear god i know
but i think it went well and at least
there was no crying well done diaz i'm
actually really glad you made me do it
this way i got to tell him that even
though it was ending
it was incredibly meaningful to me
and i'm gonna miss him
oh no this is exactly what i didn't want
you crying
i deserved that thank you for coming
diaz i want to apologize for yesterday
inserting myself into my employee's
breakup with my nephew somehow
uh backfired that's nerdfall i'm the one
that made us seem like a dumb crying
baby
i'm considering having my tear ducts
melted shut it's not the end of the
world to feel
things i guess not
it's up there
the thing is i really cared about marcus
but he wanted to get married and
i'm just not ready for that and if i'm
not ready with a guy as great as marcus
then
what if i'm never ready what if that was
it my one chance of love
and what if i never get a second chance
i don't know
i'm just
i'm just sad
well i i understand
it must be very difficult
wait are you crying yes
thank you for acknowledging my feelings
thank you for acknowledging mine
we're both great at this
what's going on
jake and him you're engaged
that's okay what you understand
love is complicated wait why would he be
okay with that when you call this dinner
you were so nervous we were worried you
were gonna tell us you were gay
so you would rather me be
some dude's mistress than be in a loving
relationship with a woman
well
jake and i aren't dating but guess what
your worst fears are real i'm not
straight i'm bisexual and i don't care
what you think about it screw this i'm
out of here
i'm also gonna go are you guys on venmo
you know what we'll figure out later
this isn't the right time
all right
so your mother and i talked about what
you told us last night we don't need to
talk about that right now we want you to
know we're not upset great i'm not upset
either because no matter what you call
yourself you still like men so you can
still get married and have a child i can
do those things with either a man or a
woman yes but it will be a man because
this is just a phase
okay that's settled ladies up
your turn me huh right
uh
a woman
uh lady
uh women two women they're holding hands
uh friends
uh
sisters oh business partners oh um oh oh
co-owners of a chocolate shop oh love
love what do women love
george clooney it's a wedding
they're brides they're in love mom dad i
know you don't want to talk about this
but
i do i might get married to a man like
you so clearly want and i might not
because this is not a phase and i need
you to understand that
i'm bisexual there's no such thing as
being bisexual yes sir is
i know there is because that's who i am
i'm attracted to both men and women
i've known this about myself for a
really long time and i didn't want to
tell you because i was afraid you were
going to react exactly like you are
what do you want us to say
that you accept me for who i am
wow
okay let's go
you